somebody asked me about boredom in their
lives so this was a woman that said her
husband works out of the home she works
from home every day he shows up and they
say what are we going to do tonight and
she said they've gone to every
restaurant in the near vicinity multiple
times they know the menu by heart they
can't find anything exciting to do that
they agree on and because of that they
either end up watching TV which they
both don't like or they go to one of the
restaurants that they've been to too
many times so think about this question
and say okay it's not just about husband
and wife I said look if we take a step
back and we think about what this
question is all about it's a question
about finding a mutual solutions a
mutual solution you have two parties and
the two parties are trying to find
something now that would be better than
every restaurant or TV but you don't
seem to find that you don't have
something that you both enjoy more than
something else that come easily to mind
so what happened is you do nothing
interesting right so I said what if we
change this a problem from a
simultaneous solution to a sequential
solution what if instead of looking
every day for something that you both
enjoy why don't you look for something
that at least one of you really love
maybe it would not maximize your mutual
happiness every day but every other day
one of you would get to do something
that you really enjoy so imagine for
example that I have one set of
preferences and you have a different
preferences in the simultaneous solution
we're looking for something that we
would both like more than TV but if that
thing doesn't exist is TV always the
right thing to do or should we one time
go ballroom dancing which is something
you really love and sometimes go to a
book club which is something I really
love and each of us would not be as
happy on that particular days when the
other person preferences coming about
but together we will do more things and
more fun things and then on top of that
I said add some random experiences into
the pile right life is about trying new
things
and sadly often we settle way too early
we try some things and we find some
things that we like but we stop
exploring we don't try lots of different
things we don't try lots of things lots
of new things because of loss aversion
because if the idea that if something is
good it's great but if something is
miserable it's really unhappy right we
really lose lots of happiness but I
suggested what you should do is put some
things in there that you don't know if
you'll enjoy or not enjoy poetry classes
things that you have no idea from time
to time you might have a miserable night
and maybe laugh at it but from time to
time it might be really fantastic